[Music]
welcome to education i'm kevin smith
and i'm andy mcelfresh oh and we are
[ __ ] hermetically sealed from one
another kids
we're zooming we're in a zoom room who's
zooming who
andy's zooming me and i'm zooming him
right the [ __ ] back
andy forgot that he was alone and he had
a mask on by oh i just saw that on zoom
and he realized why the [ __ ] would i
wear a mask by myself
as you can see andy mckelvir still lives
in harry potter's little closet under
the stairs
i have a lot more stuff than he did
[Music]
but he had a lot more magic let's be
honest that's true
he did some [ __ ] too like i'm not saying
you didn't andy wrote white chicks let's
never forget that but harry potter saved
us
all that's why i'm in this closet
[Laughter]
um this is the show kids where you get
super [ __ ] smart
um while we talk about super [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
cocktail party science uh if you will
and andy mcelfresh is the king professor
andrew mcelfish not a real professor a
professor
of uh cocktail party science if they
gave out those degrees
he would be a master in fact i just used
this ain't an ad for waterloo but like i
drank this [ __ ] and i did a pitch
like an hour ago yeah and i drank it and
somebody was like what are you drinking
is that a pabst they thought it was like
a pabst
and you know i was like it's 9 a.m but
uh
there's no blue ribbon on it yeah i was
like this looks like perhaps to you
what do i look like moore's butter maker
and [ __ ] and they're like he drank
schnitz
you [ __ ] and i'm like i knew that i
was testing you
and your bad news bears acumen you [ __ ]
no it's made from beavertain so it's
more like a pabst smear what i [ __ ]
said i brought
up to them i was like you know since i
had them and we were pitching
and you know i always like to make it as
comfortable for me as possible because
pitching is a
you know it's a it's like asking
somebody to have sex or asking them for
money
or asking god for forgiveness it's like
it's just you're you're up it's you
uphill it's you on bent knee with a hat
in your hand
asking for something it's never a very
calm it's kind of like that scene from
aliens where
the the android does the marbley peg
around the
hands and as you're going like your
heart is going faster and faster and the
thing's going faster and faster and at
any time
it could nick your hand or stab you in
the hand it's just
it's fraught being in a it's not exactly
like that i'm not saying it's like that
at all you must have just watched the
aliens and you want to talk about it bad
we can do a whole podcast about how
awesome aliens is
don't [ __ ] shoehorn it into our
education
all right all right i won't try it
anymore andy's right it is exactly like
that but it also
in many ways it's not
it can be like that what it's like is um
i was at netflix and the guy just pulls
out a knife like he really did it
they it's it's just nobody wants to be
in the asking position
you know what i'm saying i mean maybe
some people i can't think anybody that
wants to be in the asking position even
people that are
like even you know like
anybody who has their jobs like i got to
raise money for some [ __ ]
this or that politician whatever the
[ __ ] not a politician to build a damn or
whatever [ __ ]
um nobody wants that you know nobody
like
telemarketers they want something nobody
wants nobody wants to deal with somebody
who wants something so when you go into
a pitch situation
it is very much like i want your money
or a pituation
as we call it [ __ ]
master of puns professor
not a professor like that i respect that
pun game and he fed me a
[ __ ] excellent pun that i'm taking
into a pitch
tomorrow i don't want to [ __ ] i want
to tell you the joke that's a tease
if the pitch goes well and then we'll
tell you the story and kevin doesn't get
stabbed in the hand
yes the bishop lets me go and [ __ ]
you know
i guess he didn't like the cornbread
neither yes
then i will [ __ ] be able to tell you
that's all i was going for it was just a
reference to
to that audience yeah um why don't you
put her in charge
affirmative they mostly come at night
mostly mostly you'd think she was from
philly but she's not
i met her and talked to her interviewed
her for imdb she british
no she's [ __ ] american as they come
where's she from like baltimore
don't you doubt her she [ __ ] she wasn't
at the capitol
not a part of that insurrection she's
been a fake patriot she's a real patriot
as much as she's never attacked her
nation's capital in that way
andy you and i are both [ __ ] patriots
we may be super patriots at this point
because okay i've never even thought
about attacking the capital you
okay um can we go back
did you say insurrection or inch
erection
inter inter-erections when you take
that's what my
my mom called sex she didn't want to say
it because the word was
dirty right so she would say son
when you grow up and have inter-erection
and i was like what's that and she's
like that's when you put your erection
into her and then she'd run away
[Laughter]
it's probably a woman yes spry very
pun-oriented like yourself
you remind me of my mom except she ran a
lot faster than you do but you swear
faster than she ever did just joining
the show for the first time
andy was a high school swimmer so much
so that andy mcelfish's nickname
is fish yeah used to be mcfish and then
we somebody shortened it
nick fish yeah
the girls that went down on you were
like i want a piece of leo fish
well no there turns out there's a
character in the man who would be king
when they sergeant mick fish
was either in man it would be king or
another movie
but mcfish and so everybody was just
like okay that's your name and then they
changed it to fish
did they so there have been no sex fish
sex
pun related like [ __ ] oh i'm gonna i
want a little i want to blow fish
that kind of [ __ ] no i'm sorry i just
don't inspire that sort of i'm feeling
fishy as they like rub their honey on
your [ __ ]
crotch and [ __ ] it turns out i inspire
very little desire in others
i mean with the name like fish there's
so many like [ __ ] easy fish
sex puns they can make i'd like to scale
your
i don't know if i get nothing you smell
like fish and they're like what the [ __ ]
like how's it feel oh wow well
we are here to educate people yeah not
to make fun of my stupid nickname
which i almost lost and then i was
introduced to johanna my wife
by a friend who i went to college wish
with
and she said johanna this is fish
and we fell in love and i could not lose
the nickname so
there it is and at no point did johan
ever say like well i love to eat fish
no come on bro nope
she's been calling you fish all years
never once made a sexual
oriented fish pun sorry no sorry i wish
i could say yes but no
like she don't call blow jobs spear
fishing [ __ ] like that
no no you got to let me brand your sex
life
no you know what no i got off you can i
got a sunburn today but i'm still
blushing under it
you know what my second draft ready not
uh
it's uh fish heads she gives you fish
head fish
head fish head and only likes his fish
i'm really disappointed that there's
been no fish
related sex pun you're disappointed
um you bet your life i'm disappointed oh
[ __ ]
speaking of which tell me your news
well it's not you know we haven't signed
on the dotted line and so you know how
much that counts
yeah but get them to sign on the line
that is dotted
as alec baldwin said in glengarry glen
ross that's right
if any if if i can in any way inspire
you to do any part of that speech
without taking out a pair of brass balls
then i've done my work
for the day you know what it takes to
tell real estate
it takes brass balls
you moss what's your story you're such a
hero you're such a rich guy why are you
down here spending time a bunch of bumps
you see this watch you see this watch
this watch costs more than your car i
love that [ __ ] movie i do too
um but anyway it's nev never mind alec
baldwin his [ __ ] game show empire
talk about yours well uh jay leno if
you've been reading the
news so you know the news that covers
this sort of thing is going to be doing
a reboot which i know you love a reboot
i do i believe in the reboot of groucho
marx's you bet your life
and which was a style
tone setting uh [ __ ] groundbreaking
game show once hosted by groucho marx
back in what the 50s in the incipient
days of television
they took it from radio to television
it's a very low production value but it
was on for a long time
there were many iterations of it it
requires a
charming commanding host and somebody
who's quick in the moment
but also can draw on a lifetime of
of funny things and so part of the work
will be that he'll need writers to help
him
and so i will be one of those riders be
amazing if you were like and part of
that work is those drivers well
those riders will need rides and i am
going to be personally driving one of
those they will need
fresh bread to be baked
i'm like what do you mean you drive the
writers around and you're like yes
when they contact me i'm like are you an
uber
is that what you're telling me like this
has nothing to do because there's
nothing wrong with being an uber driver
but you can't start by saying that
you're involved with your life and then
it really turns out that you may perhaps
uber drive
somebody who works on the show one day
well i'm hoping what i'm
what i want to do is work with jay
because i know that at least he can stay
on target for more than eight seconds
and actually accomplish some of the
goals set out before us
but yeah it's not it's not it's not it's
not firm yet it's me
and this could kill it for me you'll
miss me blind
i know you'll miss me when you're with
jay leno making [ __ ] tv shows
and he stays to the letter of the script
periodically he'll be like i wish we
were taking some [ __ ] flight of fancy
where he just sang a boy george song out
of nowhere
yeah that's not really his style he
likes songs that rhyme and not because
they just repeat the line twice
wow you just [ __ ] took that song down
yeah four years but
do you really want to hurt me
oh boy george do you really want to make
me
cry do you really want to hurt
me that rhymes yeah do you really
what's he going to say next make me cry
oh
that worked it was a huge hit andy it
was
people he's man people like predictable
like predictability like he was the
that song was the joe biden of its day
where you're like you know what
i'm glad i know where this is going i'm
glad he just repeated himself twice
because now we're on the same page
people like the jackson five they
originally did
a b e easy as one two seven
tell you they're like hey guys guys
really great arrangement really
beautiful vocals
we gotta work on the lyrics the original
song made
every letter they were like a b c d
e f g h i j k l m
n o [ __ ] b
gordy's like are you kidding me with
this [ __ ] like you can't just
sing all the letters he's got to have
more than that
can we throw some numbers in songs have
you ever heard a song
you're just that's not a song well the
alphabet song's a song
well yeah but but it's really
uh twinkle twinkle just with bad lyrics
oh my god that's right yeah so wait who
stole what
i mean they say that mozart wrote that
tune when he was six but actually
twinkle twinkle but it actually that was
a twinkle
we can drink them i don't know what's
going on
uh but he um actually that was a
folk tune that had existed for a long
time before uh
old mozart played it on the piano
at the age of six who put uh the lyrics
to it
um the baba black sheep people
they were like that's the same song too
no baba black sheep have you any wool
yes sir yes sir three bags full of all
right wait sing that again
a b c d e
it's the conspiracy of the twinkle
twinkle
um there's something comforting about
all three songs and i guess it's because
like you know them
even if you don't know them because if
you know one you know all three
it's the mozart era version of
ding ding which appears in nine songs is
that right
can't touch this the commissar's in town
[Music]
oh can't touch this we could do a
mash-up
yeah we missed it and then you know what
that sounds like too hard of work a job
but we can do it with cats
i just got the image of cats wearing
balloon pants
how i live every day of my life i can't
escape
seeing cats wearing balloon pants wow i
[ __ ] behave the way i do
and if i do one day finally take a life
it'll be because
all i ever saw were cats and balloon
pants
doing the uh i can't touch this
yeah um this show so we congratulated
on uh him getting a [ __ ] job man well
thanks for that
i do other work you know he does andy's
always [ __ ] working and [ __ ] but yeah
that's a new
job and that [ __ ] that's that's uh
that's a show that's gonna sell
everywhere jay leno's super famous
the show is super famous and sounds like
it could be fun too
like i think it's gonna be fun game show
yeah it's not like a normal
like you gotta know [ __ ] it's you know
more like
for for those who are young listening to
this and let's be honest who are
who's [ __ ] watching or listening to
two 50 year old men
cocktail party science and they're like
i'm sorry was that the commissar
didn't that come out in like 1981 do you
want to auto tune it or like can you
talk about something in the present
but uh boy that preamble [ __ ] i
forgot what i was setting myself up for
uh you were saying uh something about
young people and
watching jay leno i think
oh yes um aggregate game show
thank you mandy for following what i
said uh the aggregate game show would be
at midnight okay remember how fun
at midnight was i do that's how fun
um you betched your life could be again
i assume i'm talking to 15 year olds and
there's not a single [ __ ]
like you know it's my mom your mom
watching this
and you know a couple people our age so
they're like you you could have just
stopped that you bet your life you
didn't have to [ __ ] say at midnight
and by the way
that's not even a current reference that
shows not on the air anymore
you used another cancelled chest
i think that working with jay you we
will be i'll be telling you a lot more
off color
jokes that i will not attribute to
anyone but you'll know where they came
from
yeah it's so funny like you know he he
works blue most people never realize
that because he's
you know being he's always like yeah man
you know might be fake on you might be
fake
but when he's on [ __ ] vegas he's like
you know what my dick is let me show you
what my
dick is my dick goes right up your
[ __ ] ass he doesn't
know that but he does do a whole section
he used to at least he used to do a
whole section on
the how amazingly big his penis is
you know he'd be like i can't wear short
pants is that right
yeah is that he's like not just jokes
and he finishes the
he finishes the uh the run with
well there's a couple of old ladies
didn't know they were getting that for
their money
you'll never look at jaywalking the same
way again yes
um about the [ __ ] success of jay
leno this show is about the [ __ ]
success of andy burkell first man
and no it's not it is and michelle first
is a professor
i am not a real professor party science
and so
every week he serves you up for
change ladies and gentlemen it's a four
chambered gun
you know not like the six shooters that
you see in cowboy movies and shows
this is more like a uh derringer yeah
a little ladies gun who's just called
what's that don't
the derringer's like two shots it's like
two derringers
is that two per deer i guess so
it's not like a derringer my my
metaphors are not working at all today
we're gonna make it work
do derringers fire two bullets at once
or separately like you get two shots and
then you throw it away i think you get
two shots
somewhere in the wild wild west you have
the one in his that goes into his sleeve
and he can go for
what was tv show or the movie tv show
the tv show
they would spend every three episodes
they would spend uh 10 minutes of him
just getting ready
to go out in his from his train and he
would go into his dressing room and turn
all the cabinets around and they would
just be
filled with weapons and he would spend
like 10 minutes just
be weaponing himself it was unbelievable
but you know as a little kid
watching tv on friday night where you
get to stay up until you know
nine that was uh
pretty amazing was there a girl
character in that show uh
every few episodes there would be a
damsel but it was
it was really it was really uh jim west
and artemis gordon
did you ever get a crush on any of the
ladies of wawa wasp
uh you know i might have been too young
how how young is too young
i had a crush on princess leia when i
was [ __ ] nine
i think i was i would have married her
at nine andy i don't mean just a [ __ ]
childish crush i mean like i was
pot committed to carrie fisher at age
nine i think it was four
five and six when that show was uh when
i was allowed to watch it
it's not too young to fall in love and
commit yourself to a woman
but it was more um you know a socratic
idea of love
the problem is she didn't know your name
because you were on t
you were watching tv while i was on tv
but if you heard your name was fish
she might be like yeah i'll [ __ ] a six
year old that's what you've been driving
at you just wanted to get somewhere
close
i did she's a fish [ __ ] didn't they
call people that had sex with you fish
[ __ ] in school like there goes that
fish [ __ ]
um that's what i'm calling johanna to
her face next time and she can't deny
it i'm like i've seen your kids you are
a fish [ __ ]
told me why would you told me that he
does that why would you
do a dirty thing and he you let him do
it
you're a fish [ __ ]
you can call me a gen [ __ ] i'll be
like you damn right
i'll be doing this [ __ ]
i can't believe it man anyway i don't
know
why you're on this toot i think it's
because you're having you've got the 30
marijuana cigarettes and not the 28
percents
2 percent makes a difference andy was i
was bitching i had like a pre-roll joint
like 28 percent thc and then i was
looking for my
30. i was like thirties like does the
two percent make a difference
and then i was like how about i [ __ ]
put 98
of my dick in your ass hold out the two
percent
and then [ __ ] you tell me i'm like
how does whose point
does that prove it's like i just
it proves that i don't know dominance i
don't [ __ ] know
um that was in the pre-game pre-show for
discussion we've had it's been actually
the conversation's been fraught
the jokes the joke doesn't work really i
should reverse it it's like
how about i put two percent of my dick
in your ass there you go
because then you could then you gotta
then that puts a man to a choice like
well two percent that's not bad and i
could win this argument if i let him put
two percent of his dick in my ass
but then again two percent you know is
98
away from a full thrust
and maybe that two percent's there just
so he can you know that's the trick
then he goes for a 98er yeah [ __ ]
um but i don't know if winning the
argument would be worth it
if that is how i would have to win it
that's well that's
why you're [ __ ] in a tiny ass closet
because you're okay to win
lose the argument yeah look at all the
space i got i never give the logistics
it'd be like
okay and then i have to take my pants i
mean it just doesn't seem like something
you and i
would do fair enough well not that room
in this room yeah this space is a desk
strong as [ __ ]
i can only get 98 of myself in this room
we're going after our baron
they're trying to satisfy our bear and
twink audience with this talk
really he's more of an otter because
like he's you know he's
but he's also kind of uh that was my
nickname before it was fish
are you [ __ ] me yeah in middle
school why
because i used to slide all around the
deck and on one of the pools i swam in
and everyone's like there goes otter
you did say deck not dick i slid all
around the dick and they were like there
goes that dick otter
he's [ __ ] hungry for he's gotta have
it
uh well here we go as we come up on our
20th anniversary of friendship
they're like otter he otter [ __ ]
change his name to fish and then that
way people that [ __ ] them
could be called fish [ __ ] yeah oh my
god
you're always thinking about practical
stuff i wish i was better friends with
johanna because i would totally get her
a fish [ __ ] jacket like
like a pink lady's jacket but said the
fish [ __ ] on the back
and she'd be in a club of like one in
ship but still why do you think being a
better friend of hers
would make a difference in terms of
giving that to her because
once you did you would not be a great
friend of hers regardless
you don't think she'd wear it around
what if it was like i don't know gucci
or something like that what does
your wife like to wear what's her design
i don't even know she has a very
eclectic taste in everything as you know
she does absolutely there's a beautiful
eye for things and so
i'm saying she has a [ __ ] eclectic
sense of style
she may [ __ ] go for a fish [ __ ]
jacket you don't know right because
you're like
because knowing her as well as i do
obviously she's gonna dress
like pinky tuscadero but instead of
having it say the thing it says in the
package says fishfucker
that is oh you're so thoughtful you
think of everything kevin
you had me got a birthday coming up you
had me at knowing her as long as
i do i mean you're absolutely right i'm
trying to sell you on an
idea where you're like you talk to her
maybe a total of
20 minutes in a year i speak to her
every day
i don't know i think you talk to her
more than that these days probably but i
mean
i don't know though bro like i watched a
cliff that's true she did say like
you're just constantly like this when
you talk to her and you're like
and i got it but it's we don't talk as
long as
like you we were talking i'm not just
talking about her and i
people don't talk as long as they
[ __ ] think they do man like you know
if you're trying to fill a two-hour
movie
you'd be shocked at how quick your
conversations go oh you talk as long as
you think you did i know because i'm
making my own [ __ ] movie but um
you're i mean you're all just
in it [ __ ] sake but in your movie
that's how you conduct yourself i'm not
gonna tell you what to do in your movie
um but so this isn't my movie
it won't depends i don't know like well
i mean we'll see who [ __ ] survives
the third act right
that two percent does make a difference
i just want to tell you
it's i'm telling you it does um all
right
getting back to the [ __ ] point yes we
got four chambers of the show just like
two like andy pulls two derringers of
knowledge on
you and empties all four barrels
to get back to the original point um
look at did you see the [ __ ]
arrogance the ego on display is andy
[ __ ] adjust his camera he's like i
want to look younger
give it up old man i just was pointing
the camera at me
the moment i you know we i had to
[ __ ] explain you bet your life to our
audience of [ __ ] 20-somethings
like we lost they all tuned out they're
like i don't get it
what are they talking about do you know
that bill cosby tried to do you bet your
life
uh it was on for one season and now he's
doing
now he's doing his own game show you're
doing life
you found a way to shut me up just by
introducing [ __ ] the word bill cosby
[ __ ] what a segway that was that's good
that was good joke good joke
um all right four chambers of this
[ __ ] show that's what i keep trying
to say but andy won't let me finish
four chambers of this show the psy
the fi the y and the by
the show is designed to tell you this up
front
so you know the journey about to take
just like twinkle twinkle little
you you know the rhythms we're going to
do there's four quadrants
that we're going to get through think of
it as a game of like you know [ __ ]
dungeons you got to get through four
whatever [ __ ] i don't know
but it's like that think about it like a
game that i can't support with any
knowledge of
you know just because you don't know
things kids think about it like
physical chemistry at a graduate level
i don't know about that um so the side
of the 5 the y and the by
and then you know you're on your way and
[ __ ] and then by i tell you by the time
you're done
you will be smart er you'll be smarter
than you were
like it's that simple or you'll feel
smarter or your money back to kevin
that's my guarantee
or your money back okay
all right there's money involved because
i've been doing this for
what nine eight years now welcome to the
world of podcasting
success is always just around the corner
yeah but i think the corner is behind us
probably look you don't do it for money
you do it for the love
man i love doing this love i love doing
it i love connecting with you
about how much you know my wife about
how comfortable i am talking about
[ __ ] about everything it's so funny
that
like you you talk about like you know
i've been doing this eight years we
haven't made any money and you say it
from the tiniest [ __ ] room
imaginable supports your argument
i'm going to put let me do a screenshot
of just you
i'm going to put that up online i'm
going to try to turn it into a meme
and it just says i am a podcaster
yes enjoying the fruits of my podcasting
here they are adult vitamin c chewables
we don't do it for the clicks we do it
for the love we'd be doing this
without y'all we did for 20 years as
andy previously mentioned we've known
each other
and we would talk to each other free for
nothing with no microphones and [ __ ]
just wasting that crap well now we're
older men and we understand that every
word is precious
we don't spill a seed no more now we put
it on wax we don't even talk to each
other unless mics are going because
what's the [ __ ] point
every thought must be recorded man
because that was where we [ __ ]
leave this world they're gonna transfer
everything we ever said
in our consciousness into a [ __ ] ipod
man we're going to live forever like
those
ipod yeah man or something small
well that was your the pitch that
finally got got me to do it
just before the tonight show was done
you're like
dude i like talking to you but i feel
like it's a waste because it's
interesting
and i was like i'm not following your
logic it's true it was important
it was wasted on an audience of one and
and you know my powers of retention i
mean i can't [ __ ] follow conversation
wearings and [ __ ] so
like you know i i would only retain
10 of the 100 gold that he would put out
there
but i could see that how the 10 percent
[ __ ] hit the people that i had
onto and [ __ ] and they're like where'd
you find that honest i got independent
study i'm smart like that
yes and then i had continuing education
in adult
education courses yeah i'm interested in
life student of life what's your [ __ ]
story
and then when we did this podcast those
same people came back to me and they're
like
you lying little [ __ ] [ __ ] you got
it all from andy and it was only a
little bit of what you remembered he
knows a lot more
he's the interesting one and you're
[ __ ] riding this coattails you piece
of [ __ ]
and they walk the [ __ ] out and i have to
live with that and think about that
i'm like oh my god [ __ ] he's right
i love it
none of this is true all right
hey man it's me kevin smith have you
been looking for all my old podcasts the
ones i started recording back in 2007.
well guess what i found them
they're all hiding in that kevin smith
club see all the video you've never seen
including exclusive movies and live
shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
do you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith
club now's your chance to club kevin
smith
all right enough with the fantasy let's
give him [ __ ] reality man
andy's got some smarts he's got his
drink and [ __ ] what is that is that
you have a cozy on that beer toppo chico
oh as i've said water from mexico what
could possibly go right
what is that why do you have it in a
cozy because
it's we're supposed to record for an
hour we've been recording for an hour we
haven't started any of this yet
so the cozy keeps it cold is that right
yeah
what a cozy does i thought it was about
like keeping it you know your hand
cozy like oh this is comfy this is
better than grabbing a bottle in a
tactile
[ __ ] way well it does have
side benefits i can't deny the ultimate
the pleasure
and be honest my hands on the san
antonio country club
koozie just makes me
so ugh i can't even describe it i'm
going to tell these keyboards here
if i ever get into that tiny ass room
years and i don't think i could fit in
there anyway
but if i do i'm going to grab that cozy
and i'm going to take a sharpie and
write fish [ __ ] on it because
that that looks like a poor man's
fleshlight man that's the only reason to
have that handy and stuffy like it's for
my drink i guarantee you pull that
topo ggo out of there and it's just
caked with
andy's fish eggs which we call
uh what was it called the nut fish you
swallowed was that
milk no the [ __ ] the fancy ones like
caviar yes caviar comes from a female
fish
what do you mean male fish produce milt
which is their semen that fertilizes the
eggs
yes so caviar would come from a
different
uh different gendered fish was i saying
that it was coming from a male fish or
something you said
it was filled with my eggs oh you're
right
yeah yeah that was just moments ago that
was
very slow it already slipped away um
it's
all right we're learning already fish
[ __ ] is called
milt yeah so have you how many people
have you know uncle melted
over their face yeah uncle milty takes
on a whole new meaning
no doubt i'm telling you right now dude
like [ __ ] since you're a fish and you
have
come that's called milk man so you could
have had like t-shirts made up that like
i got melted by fish or just got milk
[Laughter]
people like what is it spelled wrong and
you're like no you see milton's fish
coming you slapped and they walk away
oh that's hysterical all right milt milk
fish
milk mckell fish milk kel fresh
[ __ ] you shouldn't have told me that
fish gum is built
so wait are all is all fish all fish
come
called milt and all fish eggs called
caviar
i think caviar is a certain kind of fish
egg that's edible
of is that like a brand name like
band-aid and some some [ __ ] like really
i don't think there's a brand name it's
not like heroin is a brand name that
became
a normal you know like the everyday
usage name it's uh
it's what you call like i think sturgeon
row
is caviar and uh that's where like
beluga and cebruga
and all those different grades of very
expensive caviar come from and then
tompico is the little the cheepy stuff
that you mix into your
pokey when you're making pokey what's
pokey
pokey is raw tuna that is uh
it's a hawaiian dish and they cut it
into cubes and they mix it in with a
spicy sauce
and it sort of makes it like a ceviche
but
ceviche is a mexican dish of raw fish
that you mix in with
lemon juice and other things that cook
it in the acid and so it never gets
cooked in the
in like on the stove it just is cooked
by the acids you put on it
then you might put a little little
caviar on it and then you eat it
ew you don't eat much fish do you i
don't eat any fish i'm a [ __ ] vegan
you fool
and even because i mean before that i
meant to say you haven't
never [ __ ] with fish in my life man
like it's dirty they all live in the
toilet
and you've made it no they don't and
that you've made it by [ __ ] with this
fish
i do i do i [ __ ] with this fish all day
long
um you can't look at you and he got
offended and [ __ ] because i was like
fish swimming their own [ __ ] piss and
he's like this fish don't
think he runs away you know about
fish [ __ ] listen here milk face
face full of milk a mouthful of milk oh
my god is that what you say
when like you're having sex with your
wife and you're like here comes a mouth
full of milk
milk like kevin gave me some lines for
just this moment
one second honey uh here comes it wait a
second
let me turn the light on
oh my god that'd be funny well i'm
[ __ ] you gave me a joke that i'm
gonna use my [ __ ]
tomorrow i think it's only fair that you
use one of my minds and your next sexual
you've been having sex for like what 30
years with this person
mix it up throw a milt in there and [ __ ]
okay
so we got something to talk about you
can check back in like andy
did you melt her or what you're like oh
i melted the [ __ ] out of her man
they call me uncle milty all right back
to the [ __ ] show
although i think this is the show andy
feels differently he feels we have to
actually provide [ __ ] facts
i like the ongoing tease of you will get
educated
and then i like to end the show with no
education and see we all know
that yeah that's fun that takes talent
teaching people [ __ ] i mean you know
that [ __ ]
yeah teachers aren't heroes jerks
i love every teacher i've ever read i
was uh even the ones that weren't
i was just talking about potentially
learning spanish
like you know like i might want to i'm
50.
like i might want to engage and [ __ ]
with learning some spanish
and um you know i took four years of
spanish in high school but you know i'm
like the donde
celebratory and [ __ ] and i took four
years and loved it because
spanish teacher mr sheen was [ __ ]
amazing he was like my favorite teacher
man
fun absolutely [ __ ] funny he's like
think of every fun teacher from [ __ ]
movies and [ __ ] and he was that guy
like he'll show up at a party and he
didn't really do that but in the movies
they show up and [ __ ]
sometimes they show up remember that
movie uh [ __ ] um that olivia wilde
directed with the smart girls
in it yeah what was it called smart
girls
girls was in school and i can't remember
i smoked its name away and [ __ ]
and then okay i know but now i forgot
why i was even bringing the [ __ ] you
were talking about a teacher that you
loved spanish teacher because you want
to take spanish
remember in that one scene like the
teacher comes into the party and joins
the party and then winds up like they
imply that she [ __ ] the guy and [ __ ]
at the party who was a student like
that's crazy
um that didn't happen to you it didn't
but it you know i [ __ ]
i would have been okay with it because
he was so [ __ ] vastly entertaining he
didn't
he he missed his calling he was you know
i know he liked teaching spanish but
he should have been in front of a camera
or on a [ __ ] podcast he was so
[ __ ] witty and [ __ ]
like do you find like in life now that
you're in the entertainment business and
you know it's possible to get paid
just to be [ __ ] clever like don't you
think about all the people that you've
ever known that like
sincerely make you laugh and don't you
want to go like
hey man like they're waiting for you
like you can legit make a living and
show like
i i know many writers comedy writers
and comedians and a lot of them are like
well the really funny friend
is my roommate right after college or
whatever like a lot of
writers get their chops from just being
with the funniest people in the world
and learning those rhythms and that
impulse and making it a
reflex instead of just having to be
something you want to be able to do
so why so why like am i and you
and people who like make a living doing
this
like different well like you know like
oh i'm [ __ ] gonna harness this and
i'm gonna [ __ ]
like like whoever that person is the
example of like the college friend or
whatever
that cat's jack mayor jack mayer is my
that's where i got my chops was sitting
on a couch with him after college and
what does jack mayer do now he works uh
his specialty he's very good at helping
colleges
create their online accredited programs
and i'm sure he's charmed the [ __ ] out
of like whoever he's dealt with and [ __ ]
but like
you know him to be like the funniest
person you know and [ __ ]
yeah and like you know like why don't
you just do that [ __ ] and
because
most people are like oh that ain't a
realistic but it's like we live in a
world where that's exactly
what it is like who do you think's got
jobs out here it's all [ __ ] people
that are like oh it's funny to a bunch
of people and then i went and decided to
be funny for money and it's been working
out
yeah crazy i don't know but it's it's
not something he wants so it's
something he hasn't done there's nothing
wrong with that i'm certainly not
[ __ ] him a boy i'm sure he's got a
fully rolling life but what is it it's
more a question about us
like why am i so [ __ ] opportunistic
where i'm like well i'm gonna figure out
a way to use that
and [ __ ] like make a living off it
like how come i can't just because you
use that tone of voice in that face
i'll tell you one thing i go villainous
and then suddenly it turns out
bad yeah man it's crazy like
it wouldn't be enough for me to be funny
to [ __ ] four people in the world
like even if they thought i was the
funniest [ __ ] person i'd be like well
i'm done with you four
there must be more people out there i
need as many as possible
i'm sorrow i just need to [ __ ] absorb
and [ __ ] like that
what's wrong with people like us why
isn't it enough to be
funny for [ __ ] you know a handful why
is it that we're like
so empty inside that it's like i gotta i
gotta hit as many people as possible i
gotta hear as many people as possible
think that i am [ __ ] funny
speak for yourself because i never even
performed
at all except in high school i was in
um we did a high school play where it
was an episode of the honeymooners
um i played ralph cramden but then and i
also sang in college in an acapella
group which i know
you think is awesome we don't
you've made more fun of me for that than
almost anything else i'm not gonna
this one's on youtube so people are
gonna see it and i'm not gonna [ __ ] on
[ __ ]
glee clubs and [ __ ] like that they're
huge that pitch perfect series of movies
made a lot of [ __ ] money man and glee
was a show i know granted it's like 10
[ __ ] years ago but
i risk and alienating those singing
people that's right we don't want to
lose the acapella singers
no way so i'm with him he i love i mean
i'm not with him whatever he says is
[ __ ]
i think his acapella singing was a
[ __ ] and
vital part of his childhood i'm glad as
you know
a cappella is a art form most enjoyed by
those performing it
anyway that describes it absolutely
but then again so is that describes
podcasting it does
it certainly does that's why you can't
see our hands but i say that again
because i'm totally memorizing it and
stealing it and adapting it for
podcasting
okay acapella music yes is an art form
most enjoyed
by those performing it i'm going to
tweet that tonight
and you watch how many likes it gets
okay
do you want credit on it you want me to
be like you know co-written by anybody i
still got to live in the acapella world
you understand i still
i'm fine you're like look man i'd like
to take credit but i know these people
they're my people yeah if i get shunned
from that
the closet it's the closet or nothing
then i'm not even mentioning acapella
the the final version of this oh it's
gonna be podcasting
yeah what is it again podcasting no
say the acapella one it's the same i'll
just replace podcasting two years one so
closer
you said it you said the acapella one
i'll say the podcast okay
okay let's see how the attribution works
yeah you go now you're on it
don't get clever uh
noun is a
is an art form most enjoyed by those
actually performing it
so podcasting is an art form most
enjoyed by those performing it
actually in my case by those recording
it ah
there you go see that's how i take it
away from you and make it mine
yeah that's how i make it twinkle
twinkle [ __ ] that's how i'm
[ __ ] mozart man i see you're salieri
i see that hat and i put a hat on it
yeah
and you've got a little [ __ ] mask in
front of your face and you're like
place all the area
[Laughter]
all right [ __ ] let me tell you
something right now
andy's got some facts he's gonna make
you smart so smart enough
chamber one is the sigh take it away
andy this
this won't take long because i know
kevin at this point in the podcast
i can see the elevator doors just closed
and right now it's like all right
do what you must get my phone out this
is my part of the podcast the podcast
equivalent
of um like i've already came
and so you know i'm like ugh i'll just
roll over and you do what you gotta and
[ __ ]
and just i'm gonna go to sleep don't
wake me up
so this is the part of the podcast where
andy finishes
but i finished a long time ago i had my
humorous crescendo
however the fun of edumacation is that
there could be something andy talks
about which makes me laugh
even harder usually just distracts you
usually it will um it'll involve
you know somehow [ __ ] derisively
coming back to hurt andy like in the
scenario yes
yes you're starting to really pick up on
what the whole show is about kevin i've
been listening to a few and i'm like i
think i got their [ __ ] i get it now
yeah we're what do we do we're like up
to like 150 at this point and you're
just starting to really
ease now you're comfortable in the water
don't have to put your toes away anymore
no now i'm just like you know what i get
it i look it takes me a long time to get
some [ __ ] sometimes my wife has to
explain it to me
[ __ ] mulholland drive first time i
watched it i was like the [ __ ] happened
and she explained it i was like you're
[ __ ] smart that was a good movie
nobody understands that movie it's
impossible
she understood it more than me at least
and i bought her version of it
okay we'll do that in another podcast
when we're doing the
if you're gonna talk about my wife why
don't you talk about how she [ __ ] me
you know like i talk about how your wife
[ __ ] you well because it doesn't seem
appropriate to me
to ever do that telling you that's why
you know [ __ ] you're not
i don't hear you talking about how you
want to buy my wife a [ __ ] kev
[ __ ] so if somebody comes up to you
and it's like hey kev
i'd like to talk to you about how your
wife [ __ ] you and you're like this
looks like the beginning of a beautiful
friendship
it does i'm like hold on let me record
it because this is a new podcast
conversations about [ __ ] my wife with
a total stranger i'm your host kevin
smith
we'll get about 200 of these out um all
right give him the sigh mother
stop [ __ ] [ __ ] teasing them and [ __ ]
you're always like i'm
making so smart people have been
commenting online that i seem so much
kind of snippier since uh we were
recording the home edition and i'm like
that's because kevin isn't blowing
[ __ ] smoke in my face all day that's
true there's no weed to like take the
edge off
now you just have to like you're like
he's high but i'm not
yeah you can really like be like i'm not
in the same place as you okay
i don't [ __ ] i'm not high i'm not even
getting a second hand high through like
the nine masks that i wear
and i ain't mocking that i think it's
smart that andy wears nine masks
you should too kids only you're [ __ ]
if you're as talented as andy you can
make him and
if you were as [ __ ] you know
ambitious as kev smith or
entrepreneurial
you'd be selling them why don't you sell
these masks you make
because it takes a while to make them
doesn't matter
you could charge whatever you want you
got an audience and somebody would go
and you can sign them
and they'll be like oh my god i'll pay
50 bucks for a [ __ ] scheme
i got a bunch because you made it and
you signed it
all right i just feel like there would
be some liability there if anyone ever
got sick
you know what you can't [ __ ]
liability you put a little note going
like if you get sick it's not on you
wear
two masks or whatever the [ __ ] but no
way man are you kidding me
hey man you think like if you walk
around
with your dick out like you can't sue
levi's because like they didn't pant you
or something like that
like come on thing your logic again
impeccable uh but let's start with the
side now i want to keep your attention
yes so we're going to do both a familiar
bit that we've done before
but it's about comic books this is our
favorite
animal super powers what if peter parker
had
instead of being bitten by a radioactive
spider had been bitten by another
creature that was radioactive and
imparted
its powers to him what would those
powers
be platypus man platypus man
does whatever a platypus can
has poison spikes in his elbows lays
eggs and
has a flat tail look out isn't it also
like it's a mammal and a fish or some
sort of [ __ ]
it's got a dark bell yeah it's a mammal
and
what if you think it's mammal and it is
it's a platypus but is it a like
it's an egg-laying mammal it's one of
the two echidnas are the other ones
that's it yeah why do they get to be
mammals why do they get special
distinction as egg-laying mammals why
not just call them
think of a gland that sounds like the
word mammal
mammary gland yeah they are milk
producing and they feed their young
from their teats but they got eggs
yeah the eggs hatch and then they're
like what is a bird
a bird is an avian it's a
it's not a it's not a mammal in an
echidna
that looks like a bird right no it looks
more like a
it looks like a plaid foot is it really
i think it's not good no no i don't
understand why no i thought a kid knew
it was a bird but you're probably right
um what i don't get it why do they get
why don't they just get thrown in the
bird category with everybody else just
because they got a little fur
well they don't fly they don't have
feathers penguins don't [ __ ] fly
yeah but they fly underwater well can a
[ __ ] platypus swim underwater
they fly underwater too you're arguing
with the wrong guy i think you should
take this up with sir
richard attenborough if i'm anybody
listening to the show for the first time
i'm like i'm going to listen to this
[ __ ] and what he has to educate me on
he won't even acknowledge
the fact that a penguin don't fly he
flies
i did acknowledge that no you said he
flies in the water he tried to counter
me and [ __ ] like that
with your [ __ ] smart man's logic and
[ __ ]
now that i look at you in that little
room you remind me of
asked mr glass from the [ __ ] m9
timeline movies you just plotting it all
out
if you just look behind this camera
probably a bunch of newspaper clippings
about train crashes and [ __ ] like that
am i right uh yeah and kevin gets on a
train and takes his ring off
tries to hit on the girl next to him and
then is the only person to survive
i forgot the part that he takes his ring
off remember he wants to have a
conversation with her because he's
having trouble at home
yeah robin wright is ain't she ain't
into him yeah
princess bride is like princess bride's
like you know what i realized i'm
married to bruce willis and [ __ ]
he is not mr right but uh
i forgot that the ex is ringing off yeah
it's not very [ __ ] heroic
no it was very shameful of him to do and
he felt bad about it it seemed
if and it was the last time bruce willis
ever felt remorse
and let's not go nuts i don't know if he
was it was a shameful thing to do
but you know it's kind of kind of
what a bit of a dog kind of sleazy
all right i'm always terrified that the
ring is going to come off like lose my
ring and [ __ ] i was just literally
thinking today like i can't believe
i haven't lost this [ __ ] thing in
like 21 years well it's been on your
hand
yeah but sometimes it falls off like
depending on whether i've been fasting
for a week or something like that
the ring can fall right off my finger
i've woken up and found it on the floor
and i'm like either it just fell off my
finger or somebody was like
and trying to steal it in the night and
then i woke up and they ran away
and then they jump out the window they
were like [ __ ] that prospector from
[ __ ] rudolph the red nose
licking that pick and [ __ ]
all right that dude that dude is the
dude you want to catch a [ __ ] [ __ ]
from
his mouth work on that [ __ ] icy pic
he's like herme take out my keys
um all right give him this give him the
superheroes okay
what if peter parker had been bitten by
a radioactive
spanish ribbed newt the spanish
rib nude if i remember my biology
correctly
is known for its i don't well
it has its ribs it can poke its ribs
through its skin
and then it cries tears of poison
and coats the pokey out ribs with tears
of poison
and if a predator comes in and tries to
uh attack it
it poisons them with those deadly
protrusions
wait and it's tears are poisonous as
well yeah
oh my god what about spanish
has ripped the stick out and cries
poison tears
the coats his ribs that's why he kills
his foes look out
here comes spanish rib nude what i hear
in this
is that i'm going out there and [ __ ]
with
tough guys and [ __ ] who deserve it mind
you yeah
um because and i'm inviting them to like
kick my ass
come at me bro because
if they beat me up enough and i start
crying then i'm just like
whip whip and they [ __ ] die
i defeat them and i'm like hey man
self-defense
they started beating me up yeah and then
when they're
dead your kill line is i'm ribbed
for my pleasure nice if i'm using my
tears i think it would be more like
i won't cry over your demise
demise demise i have tears
demise damn eyes don't
want to
all right what's another animal that
peter parker could have been
you know this is i
i never knew this if he was bitten by a
radioactive elephant
well there are many things for example a
giant corkscrew [ __ ]
well it's not corkscrew but it's it's
their
their dicks are big enough that they can
haul up on their back two legs and use
their deck as a third leg to steady them
that's how big it is i mean but then
so if their dick is steadying them then
the dick goes where it goes
isn't dirt going with it they're not
they may not use it
just then they might go take a bath and
they take forever in the bathroom let me
just say
um so they so that's not the power that
i'm talking about
they have a power i've never heard of
they got something better than that
yeah well i mean the better it's not
like it's a competition between their
different uh characteristics
fair enough they have great memories
which is not the power
the power is ever forget that they can
create vocalizations that are subsonic
that none of the creatures around them
or humans can hear
but it travels through their feet into
the ground
and travels across to
elephants and other elephants can hear
it through their feet
up to 20 miles away that is nuts
that's nuts i mean elephants pretty
awesome
super awesome when you think about that
and having conversations with people
like 20 miles away
yeah i know i know what like if my wife
and i were elephants it would be like
can you pick up milk on the way home
it would be something like that or she
would put her feet down be like
your friend sent me a fish [ __ ] jacket
do i say
thank you i sent a thank you note or a
[ __ ]
note
um all right man [ __ ] elephants knew
now what that's not irrelevant that's an
elephant
now i'd like to uh i've got a couple
ones here but i'm going to finish up
on don't packy derm it all up andy
make sure you get one more last one in
um
[Music]
the fullmar bird the fulmar bird
when they are baby birds they're very
vulnerable
their parents are out finding food to
feed them
and left alone in the nest which is
crazy in the bird world let me tell you
i do a lot of burning these days
the young are vulnerable to everything
let me tell you kids andy is a
grade a [ __ ] bird bother man so you
trust
anything he says about birds because
he's always bothering him i'm not
bothering them
you look at him nobody wants to scare
them i deliver you were talking about a
creature eating
the bottom of your face while you looked
with your upper face
and i went right out and i found that
and i photographed it and sent it to you
i i may have laughed harder than i've
laughed in like in a long [ __ ] time
the i don't know
captured my fancy the notion of some
[ __ ] thing
eating the bottom of your face while
you're still alive so the top of your
face is looking down at your bottom face
getting eaten
you just have to know that even best
case scenario you get out of there right
now
you know you don't have a lower face
this thing [ __ ] ate it right in front
of you
so um it was so [ __ ] it captured my
imagination a big bad way
andy put up a picture of what kind of
bird was that it was a video of an
osprey
i saw it take the fish it dove down from
about
uh 70 or 80 feet in the air caught a
mullet
brought it to a branch i ran down to the
branch
and there it just took it within its
talons
and started eating the bottom of its
face while the fish is just like
what the [ __ ]
it was you could see on the video like
the [ __ ] thing is alive
yeah and this bird is just flat out
eating the bottom
of its face you know the bottom half of
the fish's head and the top half of the
fish's head is still
dealing with the fact that it's like
we're not in water what the [ __ ]
what what is this am i conquering more
oh no he eaten me
it'd be better for this thing to eat the
top half of my head and
kill me do you think anyone chooses
to like give up the struggle and just be
like that eat the top half of my head
because i ain't living with the bottom
half gone
who knows when the struggle has given up
because this thing
i didn't include the really gory video i
mean i shot for about
15 minutes there and that this mullet
[ __ ] it's like loaded
it ripped the collar out from behind the
head spit it out
it ripped out it's just ripped the
bottom of the face
and then it took its town opened up the
guts
spilled the guts out and there's other
fish
other birds coming down and eating the
the stuff that's dropping
and then the fish the tail is still
going like this and then it goes for the
head and you think oh that's it the fish
isn't going to move anymore
but i think there's must have been some
sort of autonomic response because that
thing was still
crazy flapping in its own little talon
let me ask you a question you never once
thought of going over there and saving
that [ __ ] fish
it was 40 feet in the air in a tree you
throw a rock at that bird and you make
it stop
you're the bird bother until you're not
the fish saver
which is ironic considering your name is
fish
you don't want to be the fish savior you
want to be the bird bother and you're on
the side of the [ __ ] birds that are
eating your people and [ __ ]
no i'm not going to interrupt nature's
natural course
no jake sully you don't understand man
the [ __ ] they're coming for the
avatars and the tree is [ __ ]
the blue cats man they just want to
ponytail out and [ __ ]
um what's the third third is the fulmar
it's a baby bird when it's a baby bird
and it gets attacked by another bird
that wants to kill it
and eat it eat the bottom of its face
he watches with the top of its
it face on it and it vomits a very
special
sticky substance that glues the
attacking birds
feathers together so it can't fly so now
the thing is like [ __ ] what do i do i
can't fly
and the bird that attacked its first
instinct is to go wash it off so they
jump in the water they go to the nearest
place where they can find water
and they drown because they can't move
enough to even swim
so thank god so this with its dying
breath this baby bird is like
from hell's heart i stab it
because that ain't gonna put that ain't
gonna stop the thing from eating it the
predator bird is gonna eat the [ __ ] out
of that little baby bird
this is just the last like [ __ ] you
before it dies it's like
no no the predator bird the predator
doesn't eat it
the predator word can't eat it because
it's feathers are stuck together
it vomits on the predator bird sticking
its feathers together the predator
then goes what if you're the predator
bird and you come up behind this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and eat its head
[ __ ] puke and you ain't got no time
to puke up on you
coming up behind this bird and biting in
the ass taking a big
chunk ass meat by the time this fucker's
like i gotta turn
and puke on you you could be like what
up bobby who even man
plus it's a baby i thought you were
gonna eat the bottom of my face
it's a baby bird you tell me [ __ ] a
predator bird can't outwit this [ __ ]
this baby bird's puke is a last
effort like it's this ain't like this
will save my life
this is a [ __ ] you your life is gonna
end too you
you [ __ ] chain circle of life piece
of [ __ ]
you're gonna i may be dead in your mouth
but i'm gonna be
laughing in your belly lion king three
by kevin smith
circle of life my ass that's [ __ ]
nuts man
no it really works and so imagine peter
parker like he's at the museum and
they're all screwing around and mary
jane he's trying to talk to her
and just before he gets bitten by the
radioactive spider
a radioactive fulmar chick bites him
and he just turns and it's like and
everybody gets glued together you can
stick people together with his vomit no
like let's all go to the pool
[Laughter]
that was still very cliquish they're
very popular far more
uh useful superpowers man uh
is that the last one that is three so
i'm moving on
three kids look at that there's three
three in comedy and andy's [ __ ] my
rule
[Music]